auch leute
[Musik]
es ist so ekelhaft
das hier ist nicht mehr meine fdp ich
muss das unternehmen es gibt sie noch
die guten dinge herr renschler von der
fdp sah wie schön ist richtig jetzt
haben wir ja auch dabei sagen ja selber
die partei muss aufpassen dass sie nicht
zu juvenil werden ja was heißt das ja
das heißt dass ich mich jetzt you been a
la gemacht habe weil ich aussehe im
gegensatz zu ihnen sie sehen ja jung aus
und machen sich jetzt irgendwie älter
als sie sind was sind ihre
faszinierenden vorschläge um die fdp
wieder für ältere leute zu begeistern
leute begeistern da muss erst einmal die
rentenbesteuerung von der
doppelbesteuerung befreit werden dann
darf die polizei keine jagd auf ältere
autofahrer machen die älteren klar die
gegen uns ein bisschen verloren
woran liegt's
ich würde mir sondern biologisch
ach so dass das alles so den sein seinen
regisseur schöpfer vorgesehen hat
vermutlich auch ein altes huhn gibt noch
eine gute suppe ich wollte nur sagen
dass auch die alten automobil hip sind
wieder nicht also urteil scheinbar ja
ich wollte nicht noch nicht nur das sie
sind sehr kostbar und sehr teuer
manchmal aber teurer als ursprünglich
als sie gebaut wurde schlucken natürlich
relativ viel
ja gut dass sogar auch nicht nicht
schlimm ist also kommt darauf an was was
es bei unserer zeit immer geheißen dass
ihre altäre partei und diesen ruf und
jetzt auf einmal wird cannabis
freigegeben ja
ja
wobei jeder beißen schöner trollinger
tut's auch natürlich haben die
jugendliche mögen halt nicht so gern die
cannabis was ist das für eine welt weiß
ich auch nicht dass ein linker oder die
partei tut ja auch was für die alten
leute 100 milliarden neuverschuldung und
das zahlen erst die enkel also von daher
gesehen jeder rentner wird sagen jetzt
ich bin raus und bin fein aus dem
schneider ja da ich aus dieser
generation wäre kann ich nur sagen alles
was wir jetzt tun um den frieden zu
sichern ist richtig angelegtes geld ist
nützt hier unseren enkeln nichts dass
ich ein zerstörtes land übernehmen
einfach dankbar sein konnte sondern auch
bezahlen meine enkel sind auch dankbar
sie freuen sich jeden tag wenn sie mich
sehen und sagen das machst du ist das
nicht irgendwie auch den befreien dass
sie also zum beispiel auch sagen können
der bundeskanzler ist eine pfeife jetzt
in der derzeitigen situation das kann
man sich doch mal ein bisschen dass die
reife des alters ankommen können sie
meinen mann sagt so was nur wenn man
wenn das wenn man selber aus dem letzten
loch pfeift nein ich will nicht er
vielleicht nicht mehr pfeifen alle
zusammen und dann will ich ihm endlich
persönlich gegenüberstehen den tick tock
mastermind der fdp kollege heubisch
was ist sein geheimnis
christian lindner dazu dass die ethik
durchmachen ja ich glaube dass es weiß
aber in einer liberalen partei macht
jeder das was er für sich für richtig
dass die partei von land zieht sich
genscher von walter scheel
yoga für die helden warten
es war doch die tik tok von vor 40
jahren das war auf jeden fall das
grauenhafte was die deutsche politik
bislang hervorgebracht hat ich mache das
seit er vor allen dingen die
mainzelmännchen die meisten haben ja ich
habe einen kollegen von ihnen sogar
einst gemalt dass man gar nicht schlecht
sie müssen wir mal bei instagram gucken
ja da finden sie in meinem profil ein
selbst gemaltes mainzelmännchen von jan
tempo 100 nicht einführen aber mir meint
für manche meinen das habe ich gerne
hören sie werden jetzt melden dass das
wegen des mainzelmännchen tempo 100 mg
eingeführt wird vermutlich oder das ist
die top news des abends dann können sie
mir dann zu dieser meldung dann wieder
viele fragen stellen und damit dieser
investigativen entdeckung gebe ich
zurück ins studio da sind daniela
tröster noch alle mainzelmännchen
gut immerhin etwas
so
aufnahme
hallo dies ist die automatische and cut
von oliver welke und der heute show
leider ist das video schon vorbei ihr
könnt den kanal allerdings gerne
abonnieren und ein weiteres video
anschauen vielen dank so müsse jetzt für
immer reicher